you're [ __ ] stupid if you don't
believe in the Second Amendment because
every society doesn't have it Cuba
doesn't have it you can't revolt against
the government you can't Revolt right so
in Mexico you don't you don't have that
type of luxury right you don't have the
luxury of like protecting your family
imagine they roll up to your house right
and they want to take your family the
cartels where you can't even shoot back
you just gotta let it happen or they're
going to kill everybody in the family
right tell you one last story before we
move on there was a couple of guys that
were selling drugs there in guadala
the two brothers they decide they don't
want to they're part of the cartel I
don't know what happened things are a
little hot for them they're like you
know what we want out we want to retire
so they left to Texas because Texas is
right there
they're the last name is Garza you guys
could actually look this story up and uh
the cartels so you have one day to come
back and if you don't come back we're
gonna kill everybody with your last name
in the surrounding area and that's
exactly what they did that's exactly
yeah so that's exactly what they did
they um they went in there they
eliminated everybody with the same last
name so that's how bad it gets even if
you don't yeah
that's you know saying even if you don't
know what you pay it because that's just
the way things go so being in America
you don't have to worry about things
like that I think people take it for
granted and they become sissies over
here damn you know touching upon what
one of the things that he said um I
believe in the Second Amendment but
there like there's so many polarizing
things here happening in the United
States that you're you either we're
getting split up into extremes right so
there are a lot of people that are for
Second Amendment and they're like don't
take away any [ __ ] gun it's it's like
they're at one end of the spectrum and
then there's a bunch of other people we
try another end of the spectrum that are
saying we shouldn't have guns why Canada
doesn't have guns the United Kingdom
doesn't have guns why do we have guns
and I'm somewhere I want to say in
between I'm pro-gun I have a gun but I
don't believe in the AR-15s I don't
believe in these guns that are doing
that are going out there and kids being
able to get these guns very easily going
out there and going into schools and
doing whatever you know wherever they go
and people coming into the workplace I
think that we should have that second
amendment I do believe that we should
have guns because I know what happens
look at the Ukraine look what happens to
Cuba look what happens to all these
people they get bullied right and if the
people can't stand up for themselves
they're screwed so I believe definitely
we should always have that right to
stand up for ourselves yeah but I
believe we shouldn't take it to the
extreme you know you're not hunting deer
with an AR-15 you know you're not
there's there's no need for some of
these yeah but but but the second
amendment was never intended to hunt you
get a deer it was meant it was meant to
be able to protect your family and
against a tyrannical government you
can't do that with the name I own AR-15s
a lot of them uh you can't do that with
the nine millimeter pistol you just
can't you know and and I by the way I
100 I can't agree with you I 100 agree
with you
um I don't like the fact that you could
just go like in California we have a
10-day cooling off period And by the way
as pro-gun as I am I think every state
should have that like in Texas you can
go and buy a gun right now this instant
if you're hot after having a
conversation with Michael you'll go kill
him
as far as the type of gun I wanna like
the military has tanks my little AR-15
ain't gonna do nothing against them so
when you compare does that make sense
but what I'm getting at is that uh I
think a Trader cooling off period uh
everybody already has background checks
we already have that like people like we
need more background we already have
them but 10-day cooling off period uh
loud and then not only that it gives the
government in California 10 days to
catch any felons or misdemeanors that
you may have so then they can deny the
gun from you so I think every state so
that's going back to fixing what you're
saying I 100 agree with you I don't
think an 18 year old kid should be
running because I own them I don't think
an 18 year old kid should be running
around with an AR-15 at all I don't
think they're responsible enough but
going back to like I said you know I do
want to be able to defend my family in
case you know nine millimeter ain't
gonna do it you know because well I
think what you're both are saying is
there's some needs to be some common
ground it shouldn't be zero guns no no
sorry like no you get nothing and it
shouldn't be like you can walk around
with a freaking bazooka there needs to
be some sort of moderation you should
not be able to an 18 year old kid had
and should not be able to go into a
store and walk out with an AR-15 row now
I'm talking because I own them yeah you
should not be able to there should be
age limits on this I think for look for
an AR nine millimeter whatever I think
21. I'm and again a lot of my buddies
are gonna watch this or not because I am
Pro Second Amendment on pro gun I don't
think you should own AR-15 too you're 25
years old I would still be able to pass
you know but some people are going to
say that's very unamerican if you're
rich I don't really give a [ __ ] that's
what they think because at the end date
well he's right you know there's certain
things there's certain things that you
get bullied in school whatever that's at
least at 25 you're you're because you're
what is it the front the lopi what is
that thing called right here in the
front it stops developing at 26. so
you're thinking a little bit more wiser
how did he go from the king of Miami of
partying yeah to philanthropist because
he grew he matured so you need to go
through that process as an adult of
course and I think at 18 you don't raise
you know I know at 18 you get [ __ ] it
was Game Over You know what I mean so if
you like that clip click right here to
watch another or if you want to watch
the entire saucecast click right here
[Music]